Speaker 1: Major breaking news over the last
24 hours, including 1717 guilty counts for
the Trump organization in this massive New York
investigation that has been going on for some
time. It involves Trump's former CFO, Allen
Weisselberg. This is a major story which has
instantly triggered the failed former president.
But let's not get ahead of ourselves. Let's
go through it piece by piece. New York Times
reports Trump Organization Found Guilty in tax
fraud scheme. The former president's company had
been accused of providing off the book benefits
to executives. The testimony of its former chief
financial officer proved crucial to the case. So
what exactly is it that happened? The conviction
on all 17 counts. After more than a day of jury
deliberations in state Supreme Court in Manhattan
stemmed from the company's practice of doling out
off the books perks to executives. They receive
luxury apartments, leased mercedes-benz's extra
cash at Christmas, even free cable television,
and they paid taxes on none of it. This is a
very simple thing. My accountant has talked to
me about how this works many, many times before.
Imagine that you have something very simple.
Okay? You have your business leases, you a car,
a beautiful vehicle, drives you around for
wheels, tires. The entire thing can go forwards
and backwards. Okay. Gets you where you need to
go. Let's imagine the leases to pick a number
$500 a month, which is $6,000 for the year. The
business pays the $6,000. It's a business expense
for the business, $6,000 in lease costs. But if
that vehicle is only available to one person,
really, it's considered a fringe benefit. And that
$6,000 should be added to that individual's W-2,
and then you pay taxes on it. You don't get
the six grand, you get a lease worth $6,000,
and then you pay taxes on that $6,000.
Now, $6,000 is very quaint because what
we're talking about here is luxury apartments.
I believe at issue also was educational expenses
for family members of Allen Weisselberg and
potentially others. So you're talking about
a lot more money. This is classic stuff. And
the idea that this is obscure or in some way
petty is absurd. Any reasonable account will tell
you, you know, this is the way that it has to go.
Going back to the article, the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office, which prosecuted the case,
previously obtained a guilty plea from the
architect of the scheme, Allen Weisselberg,
the longtime CFO and Weisselberg ultimately
testified as the prosecution's star
witness but never implicated Trump. Very
important prosecutors didn't charge Trump,
but they invoked him throughout the trial, telling
jurors he paid for some of this stuff and even
approved a basic aspect, a crucial aspect of the
scheme. Importantly, the verdict carries limited
financial repercussions and will not directly
threaten to imperil Trump's company. But the
conviction and the prosecution's explosive
claim in closing arguments that Trump was,
quote, explicitly sanctioning tax fraud
could reverberate during his nascent 2024
presidential campaign and provide fodder for
political opponents. So 17 guilty verdicts,
but not going to imperil Trump's company. Here
is the report from MSNBC. As the news came in.
Speaker 3: A scheme that would basically try
to compensate top executives or help these
executives avoid paying a go to, well, what is it?
Speaker 4: Guilty on all counts. We have a verdict
this guilty on all 17 counts just in moments
ago after about 10 hours of deliberations.
And you're right, Howie, this is a case against
the Trump Corporation, two entities of the Trump
Corporation. There were no named individuals.
Former President Donald Trump was not named.
But certainly this this is his family company.
This is his livelihood. This is his business.
This is his reputation. This is all things
Donald Trump, except him being named as a
defendant in this case, you might say so.
Speaker 1: That is from MSNBC. CNN also
had the report of the verdict.
Speaker 2: What do you know?
Speaker 3: Well, Victor, that's right. The jury
just returned a verdict. Guilty, guilty on all
counts against both Trump corporations. Entities.
That means that the jury, after two days of
deliberations and four notes today, came back with
this decisive verdict, unanimous, guilty on all
counts. Now, remember, the two Trump Organization
entities were accused of being involved in a
15 year tax fraud scheme where they gave their
executives, certain executives, off the books.
Compensation. That was corporate apartments that
were rent. That was company cars. That was private
school tuition for Allen Weisselberg, the chief
financial officer, his grandchildren. The jury
finding the companies were guilty on that. Now,
Donald Trump, former president, was not charged
in this case, but its name did come out at the
trial, including on closing statements. One of the
prosecutors saying that he believed that Donald
Trump had sanctioned some of this tax fraud.
Speaker 1: Of course he did. And as
Michael Cohen has spoken about many times,
Trump knew exactly what was going on. 17 guilty
verdicts. Let's now go to Donald Trump's reaction.